all right star wars visions has dropped
on disney plus and it is exceptional uh
and i want to talk about
cultural appropriation and
uh you remember back on episode 1267 i
was talking about cultural sharing
versus cultural appropriation
and here is the 52nd clip of what i said
i'll talk on the other side this is back
when i was in italy at the beach writing
the book
disney plus is doing six different
japanese animations studio has charged
six different japanese animation studios
to produce nine short films in anime
style of
star wars stories they're calling it
star wars visions
so let's take a moment
and look at how
cultural sharing and inspiration can
produce amazing products in the world
some people will like to focus on
you know tearing each other down for
being inspired
a white woman being inspired by chinese
noodles well let's take a moment here
and just think
about how amazing it is that the french
directors inspired kurosawa kurosawa
inspired
lucas and now lucas is inspiring
japanese animators and anime this is
great and uh if you're watching this on
youtube you can see the trailer i cannot
wait to see this all right so just as a
follow-up to that it was released um
just uh on september 22nd and i'll play
a little b-roll from the first episode
which is i think called the duel and it
is amazing it is literally
yo jimbo
you know seven samurai inspired kurosawa
uh but with lightsabers and in a
beautiful animation style and my
five-year-old twins loved it my 11 year
old loved it i loved it my wife loved it
we all thought it was brilliant um and
i want to just one more time talk to you
about how wonderful and beautiful the
world can be and how the people on
social media who are complainers and
whiners frame it in a negative fashion
to get likes and to virtue signal and
how we should all collectively as a
society ignore these whiners who are
trying to create strife in our society
and we should think about the builders
and the creators and what they're doing
people who complain and whine
professionally the whining class of woke
whiners on social media who produce
nothing in the world
are not important you know who is
important in the world
the designers the artists the writers
the creators the entrepreneurs the
studios the people who manifest beauty
and services and products that inspire
us and make us want to wake up every day
those are the people who matter in the
world not these complainers
and you know
the the reference i made in that clip
was to this woman who studied noodles
and had a passion for noodles she wasn't
chinese but she loved noodles and she
liked showing people how to make noodles
and was making a cookbook and was
sharing her passion for chinese noodles
and dumplings
can
an american not be inspired by
chinese culture can chinese culture not
be inspired by japanese culture be
inspired by korean culture be inspired
by
french culture that's the world we want
we actually want
cultural sharing and appreciation
and you can frame almost every one
of these instances
from cultural appropriation and just
pause for a second say what was the
person's intent
were they intending to appropriate and
take and steal from somebody in some
cases sure that exists as a thing but we
are looking for every single chance to
say this is cultural appropriation as
opposed to appreciation and i would just
like you to think for yourself it's
going to be a big theme on this podcast
of thinking for yourself critically
appreciation is when somebody actually
wants to
learn about the other culture and
embrace it and love it and uh
you know kurosawa was a major
inspiration to lucas scorsese etc um
lucas inspired takashi and
kami kaze the director writer and
animator of the duel
and that's absolutely beautiful and i
highly recommend this series and i
highly recommend we all pump the brakes
and appreciate each other and appreciate
the art that we all make as societies
the food
the fashion and just
pay tribute to each other and we used to
get trained in school that america was
the melting pot where everybody added
something to the soup of america and i
think we need to get back to that i
think one of the reason we have all this
division is because people are focusing
on everything that makes us different
as opposed to pausing for a second and
thinking about how much we have in
common and how much we appreciate each
other
uh just me and david sacks as an example
david sacks is a republican we fight on
the podcast all in
about the rush he calls of the russian
hoax i i have to remind him like hey
listen all these
the russians were interfering and i've
been working with sacks offline to say
because a lot of people have been
bringing this up to me
hey you know we have a difference of
opinion you know he's more conservative
i'm more liberal i guess but
we actually
uh both agree that russia's an enemy and
they're both trying to manipulate
americans we need to have some
leadership here in this country that
says
hey
russia is not a democrat versus
republican thing and democrats trying to
catch republicans in cahoots with
russians or russians trying to
compromise
you know
the nra to make
uh republicans look bad and that they're
in on the take and all these spies we
need to have a united front against
russian interference or we need to be
united against the competition with
china this is an existential threat to
everything we do
let's start thinking about americans as
having 80 90
95 percent of the same fabric and the
same belief system and the same
appreciation of each other and yeah for
five ten twenty percent different viva
la difference that that's great you like
to make chinese food i like to make
japanese food somebody likes to make
indian food great that's what that's our
strength here let's lean in to cultural
appreciation
from websites and online stores to
marketing tools and analytics
squarespace is the all-in-one platform
to build a beautiful online presence and
run your business with squarespace you
know you can blog and publish content
you can promote your business you can
announce upcoming events or special
projects and you can sell products and
services of all kinds and more no matter
what the problem squarespace is the
answer they have beautiful templates by
world-class designers that's kind of
where they got started and everybody
noticed like whoa look at these
beautiful designs but they've added so
much functionality since that time
including powerful ecommerce
functionality and everything is
optimized for mobile right out of the
box it's got built-in seo free and
secure hosting and of course their 24 7
award-winning customer support back in
2020 we decided we create
remotedemoday.com
for founders to pitch thousands of angel
investors over resume well we purchased
the domain name remotedemoday.com and
had the site up and running within
minutes from idea to execution in just
minutes and incredible functionality so
you can grow with them and it's been a
huge success for so far i mean we've
invested tens of millions of dollars at
kids or not so go to squarespace.com
twist for a free trial and when you're
ready to launch use offer code twist to
save 10
off your first purchase of a website or
domain and congratulations to the team
for going public on may 19th what an
amazing journey it's been amazing to
watch squarespace grow and become such a
vibrant company and congratulations on
that milestone